madeleine le marais et martin biron
bonsoir allons-y avec notre panel avec
un petit retour sur la semaine mais
d'abord mais d'abord je veux qu'on
commence
madeleine par parler de ce qui suivit de
se produire au cours de la dernière
heure je vois sourire mais c'est
intrigant même en un tweet qui laisse
entendre que l'équipe la garde
rapprochée de monsieur trudeau publié un
compte rendu d'un entretien avec
monsieur autour d'entretiens qui n'avait
toujours pas eu lieu c'est bien ça oui
c'est exactement ça en fait a été
confirmée par le bureau du premier
ministre en disant que ça a été une
ébauche de la vie de chat rencontre que
ce qui ne s'était pas produite
finalement à bon on peut que ça peut
être anecdotique ce que son erreur mais
si on peut lire toutes sortes de choses
là demain premièrement moi j'ai
l'impression que les journalistes en ce
moment qui sont pas complètement
malheureux de voir ça arriver parce que
les comptes-rendus qu'on a du bureau du
premier ministre sur les rencontres qui
qu'il a avec d'autres chefs d'état de
gouvernement des des premiers ministres
si jamais détaillé
donc cessez jamais précis ça démontre à
quel point on ne peut pas tant
d'informations que ça sur ce qui se
déroule véritablement dans les
rencontres et c'est normal que le
premier ministre arrive avant la
rencontre avec des sujets qu'il veut
aborder donc c'est normal que l'équipe
du premier ministre sache déjà en gros
quels sont les points qui seront abordés
pendant la rencontre
donc qui les a préparés d'avancé moi ça
ne surprend pas trop ça paraît pas ça
paraît pas bien qu'il dévoile le content
du compte rendu d'une rencontre qu'il
n'est pas qu'ils n'ont pas encore eu
lieu ça c'est certain c'est que c'est
une gaffe l'homme et ce n'est pas une
gaffe très très graves des choses un
dernier point naturel et qui parce que
le deuxième paragraphe du compte rendu
de la rencontre mais pollue lieux parle
de désinformation de la part de députés
conservateurs donc le bureau du premier
ministre envoyée des reproches au parti
conservateur et ça je trouve que c'est
quand même éloquent dans le contexte
actuel on est dans un contexte de
gouvernement minoritaire ou je trouve
que de part et d'autre on a fait de plus
en plus les couteaux en vue d'une
potentielle élections tout le monde se
prépare en vue des élections au
printemps et j'ai l'impression que ça
témoigne de sa un peu il un compte rendu
là où les attaques sont plus virulentes
à l'endroit de
conservateurs et les conservateurs ont
été quand même assez dur aussi envers
les libéraux cette semaine sa faute il
s'en surprendre et martin camp des
adversaires politiques comme ça saute
sur l'occasion peu importe le contexte
pour avec un parfum d'élections au loin
un profiter la situation ont tenté de
faire je suis du même avis que madeleine
les trois dernières lignes de ce mémo là
sont quand même importante parce qu'il
vise carrément les conservateurs de
l'alberta et on a appris cette semaine
qu'il y avait une dissension importante
en alberta entre le politique le premier
ministre jason kenney et la santé
publique concernant les actions à poser
dans le cadre de la cause il ya des cas
ça explose comme en alberta et c'est un
message à peine voilé de ceux de se
gouverner alors la question
évidemment je connais moins bien les
stratèges politiques à ottawa
madeleine est meilleur que moi là dessus
mais mais c'est vendredi et si on veut
que l'information circule bas il faut
généralement la diffuser un peu plus tôt
alors l'appel téléphonique a lieu
présentement si je comprends bien et
nous on en parle ce soir et on en parle
je pense d'un bout à l'autre du pays on
verra ce qui en sera finalement de cet
appel quand ce sera terminé
si le compte-rendu va être modifié
véritablement il ébauche où on va avoir
droit à un peu plus de détails ce serait
bien avisé qu'il nous donne finalement
une autre version
petit conseil en passant si on peut s'y
attendre on peut les aider talent c'est
ce qu'on aime avoir envié de radars sur
les conservateurs un peu plus tard sur
la question du français ça c'est sûr
mais la vaccination qui plan en vue pour
ses campagnes massives de vaccination
inédite dans l'histoire du canada ben
les choses se précisent de plus en plus
avant d'en parler davantage écoutons là
dessus justin trudeau certainement une
un désir d'être d'arriver à la ligne de
départ le plus rapidement possible et je
comprends ça aussi mais il faut aussi
parler d'eux quand on arrivera à la à la
ligne d'arrivée et ça à ce niveau là les
docteurs ont souligné qu' il ya de très
bonnes chances si tout fonctionne bien
qu'on puisse vacciner vacciner à la
majorité des canadiens d'ici septembre
prochain
c'est ce qui compte c'est la ligne de
départ nous dit monsieur trudeau s'est
d'abord in d'arriver à d'arrivée par
dont il veut mettre l'accent là-dessus
d'abord et avant tout aujourd'hui il
veut mettre l'accent là dessus parce que
la ligne de départ elle est plus loin
pour le canada qui est nulle et pour
d'autres pays notamment l'allemagne les
etats-unis parce que le canada n'est pas
un pays producteur de ses vaccins contre
lacko vide ce qui fait que les pays
producteurs veulent se servir d'abord
son peut le comprendre ce qui était
particulier cette semaine c'est que
justin trudeau en parle justement cette
semaine alors qu'il n'avait plus
vraiment le choix de le dire
sachant que d'autres pays était sur le
point d'approuver les vaccins et de
commencer à recevoir des doses donc
justin trudeau a mis la table cette
semaine et leurs sacs ont été importants
les partis d'opposition lui ont dit
pourquoi on sera plus tard que d'autres
pays pourquoi on sera derrière au bout
de la ligne ce qui est peut-être un peu
exagéré on sait toujours pas exactement
où on se situe dans la ligne de tous les
pays mais j'espère que dodi bon regarder
la ligne d'arrivée c'est important la
ligne d'arrivée évidemment mais la ligne
de départ elle est importante aussi
parce que lorsqu'on commence et muni
zélés populations les plus vulnérables
ce qui est le cas ce qui est prévu qu'on
commence par les personnes qui sont les
plus à risque ça donne de l'oxygène au
système de santé
évidemment personne ne doivent être
baisser la garde mais ça permet un peu
tout le monde de respirer un peu mieux
oui et les provinces qui attendent aussi
les détails martin le québec qui a déjà
ses plans ses ébauches mais on est un
peu dépendante ce qui se passe à tahoua
ouais c'est ça et en fait il ya deux
question c'est combien de doses et quant
à partir de ce moment-là faudra les
distribuer comment elles seront
distribuées ou si le
monsieur le premier ministre hugo a
parlé de trois millions de doses d'ici
mars
combien est-ce que le québec va en avoir
alors si on y va au prorata de la
population ce sera environ 23% donc à
peu près en bas de ces cent mille doses
alors qui est-ce qui sera prioritaire
les personnes âgées sûrement les
travailleurs de la santé peut-être même
avant certaines personnes âgées parce
qu'on sera pas capable de vacciner tout
le monde d'ici mars dans ces créneaux
spécifiques
l'autre chose qu'on devra se poser si ou
qu'est-ce qu'on privilégie les centres
urbains en premier les régions est ce
qu'on va dans les régions où il ya plus
d'éclosion saluant ben oui ah oui on va
partout en même temps est-ce qu'on se
déplace
est-ce qu'on fait venir des gens ce
rendez vous en tout cas c'est une
logistique incroyable qui va demander
beaucoup de précision et qui va demander
aussi de la pédagogie parce que bon il
ya 20% de la population que qu'à 65 ans
et plus
on n'est pas là ça va être long alors
les gens vont devoir continuer à suivre
des consignes pendant pas mal de temps
encore oui on parle de 6 millions de
doses d'ici la fin mars qui permet de
vacciner trois millions de personnes
puisque 2002 doses par personne
donc évidemment on peut pas vacciner
tout le monde pour ce kit la liste de
priorités le gouvernement fédéral a déjà
émis des grandes lignes directrices mais
comme c'est le cas pour d'autres aspects
de la pandémie c'est après aux provinces
de décider effectivement cette décision
là elle est difficile à prendre
notamment en raison de la complexité
logistique martin le disais quand on
doit transporter des vaccins comme ça à
moins 75 degrés celsius maintenir la
ligne de froid du début à la fin
c'est un défi logistique incroyable
justin trudeau parler de la campagne de
vaccination la plus importante de
l'histoire du canada et c'est pas pour
rien aujourd'hui qui le nommer un haut
gradé de l'armée des forces armées
canadiennes pour s'en charger ça lui
permet du même coup d'une certaine façon
de se parer contre les critiques
notamment les critiques des
conservateurs je vous en parle
tout à l'heure et se donne finalement
incertain et boucliers en disant voici
j'ai un major général dany fortin qui
sera en charge
donc ça mais le politique un petit peu
en arrière plan ce qui est pas
nécessairement une mauvaise stratégie et
de la même manière on a eu droit aux
premiers à la première séance de
breffage technique cette semaine de la
mare de la santé publique
de hauts fonctionnaires de santé canada
qui qui approuvent les vaccins donc
c'était encore une fois mettre des
experts à l'avant scène et non des
politiciens qui peuvent être critiqués
si jamais ça jamais il ya des problèmes
il ya plus plus loin dans le processus
il va falloir aussi convaincre un
certain nombre de personnes dessus à
vacciner parce que la résistance
il va y en avoir et il ya un seuil
évidemment à atteindre il faut affûter
j'imagine aussi le message porte pour
cent ce qui concerne cet aspect des
choses puisqu'on parle d'un message là
on change un peu d'aspects on parle des
fêtes de noël qui approche à grands pas
et des plans de match qui sont mis de
l'avant un peu partout au pays
ça peut sembler un peu cacophonique pour
les gens qui observent c'est ce que
diatta oise que du québec et de
l'ontario
on va dans un premier temps s'attarder
au cas du québec écoutons monsieur
legault un contrôle qui a la foi est
simple mais en même temps je me rends
compte ce point noir ou blanc l'idée de
donner rapidement une orientation
c'était pour que les gens puissent se
préparer dès que je les dis jeudi
dernier j'ai mis un gros si si les
situations ce maintien si on garde le
contrôle de la pandémie certain martin
ont parlé de confusion dans le message
ce que monsieur legault a réussi à à
simplifier la chose à reprendre le
contrôle de la situation
oui il a simplifié les choses mais ce
faisant alexis il a lâché du lest c'est
sûr que plus le cadre est stricte plus
c'est difficile d'entrer dans le cadre
c'est pas tout le monde qui vit la même
situation que quelqu'un qui est dans une
famille par exemple reconstitué avec de
la garde partagée et pas du tout dans la
même situation où
deux adultes en télétravail qui ont deux
enfants télétravail également alors cccc
seul qui devenait compliqué et le
gouvernement se retrouver dans une
situation où il devait régler chaque
petit cas qu'on lui soumettait
alors il dit écoutez considérez vous
comme contagieux vous et vous des
questions sur qui vous devez recevoir et
qui vous ne pouvez recevoir
faites attention là la quarantaine
étaient strictes au point de départ
avant la période de noël
elle semble l'être - alors c'est ça du
coup il a lâché un peu de lest
alors est-ce qu'il soit aura un impact
sur le niveau de contagion au vert la
deuxième chose c'est le fameux ci parce
que ce n'est pas la fin de l'histoire on
ce métier quand même à mille deux mille
trois cent mille 400 cas par jour c'est
énorme ce haut plateau et monsieur
legault se réserve une plage horaire je
vous irez qui va se retrouver à quelques
jours de noël probablement autour du 17
décembre pour dire aux citoyens ben
écoutez je remets de la pâte à dents
dans mon tube et je ne vous permets pas
autant de rassemblement on verra comment
ça va se passer mais quand on regarde
les chiffres actuels c'est pas
c'est l'ambiance n'est pas à la fête
ouais c'est pas de bonne augure tout ça
on se croise les doigts on verra pour
ces chiffres et leur évolution
le temps a passé plus vite que je le
pensais alosi sur la situation du
français
je vous entends des deux là dessus
monsieur o'toole qui de toute évidence
enfin une priorité à se colle sur
certaines des positions du gouvernement
le goût recentre le message du parti
conservateur madeleine oui c'est une
nouveauté en depuis que renault tour est
arrivé à la tête du parti conservateur
on a opéré un virage pour ce qui est de
la question linguistique entre autres
cette position de dire que les
entreprises sous juridiction fédérale
devrait être soumise à la loi 101 au
québec ça c'est nouveau de la part du
parti conservateur
on vise visiblement les sièges
francophones du québec et là ce sera une
bataille je vous parlais tout à l'heure
des élections ce sera une bataille le
québec francophone et c'était
particulier de voir ce à la chambre des
communes y avait un débat cette semaine
sur la question d'un physique et on
sentait très bien que les libéraux les
conservateurs le bloc québécois parlait
de la langue mais j'ai l'impression
qu'ils avaient tous sans arrière-pensée
ses sièges francophones au québec où le
champ de bataille sera féroce assez
intéressant de voir comment monsieur
legault entre dans cette dynamique
martin oui ben on sait que le ministre
simon jaulin barrette est en train de
préparer un projet de loi qu'en
sera-t-il déposé on parle de cet hiver
c'est reset un petit peu plus tard que
tout parce que nous sommes en pleine
pandémie et monsieur legault n'a pas
envie de donner des obligations
supplémentaires notamment par exemple
aux entreprises ou aux différents
du gua différentes écoles par exemple où
différents secteurs en pleine pandémie
et on regarde dans les médias
anglophones on voit que les anglophones
sont assez craqué alors on veut garder
profil bas optant qu'on est en pandémie
alors ça risque de venir sous tard que
tout cet hiver c'est délicat quand même
tout ça en bas merci beaucoup pour ce
panel
on n'oublie pas la mise à jour
économique d'ottawa la semaine prochaine
en début de semaine le dit c'est ça
allez au revoir et ils répondent bien au
revoir